and that celebrity was accused of grape
that celebrity was accused of grape once
and that celebrity
or that person
went to jail for a certain amount of
time for it
what that person done after getting back
out
is that they put camera recordings
or cameras sorry in their bedroom
and one day and he used to record he
would see women blah blah blah do you
know what i mean he see women
and
one day he had sex with a woman
and then in a couple days she had
accused him of grape
again second time now
however the cameras
recorded the fact that he didn't do that
and he won his case
so
i know a lot of women
don't want to be recorded in their
intimate moments right
but the reason why i'm asking this
question is because of cases like this
cases like johnny
um
how would you feel as a woman
being recorded without your consent like
that
this is as long as he's not
sharing it or showing it to anybody
go for it we'll make a movie you can
record me go for it
but
in that let me know
in that sense i don't
i think if it's for
like protection he should be able to
anybody should be able to record it just
in that case that it doesn't happen
again false allegations don't happen
again
like i said don't show anybody
yeah as long as it doesn't hit the
internet then it's fine because once it
hits the internet that woman can
technically now bring a case against you
for sharing pornographic images of her
but without her consent and that's a
thing now
that's why it's been a thing yeah
but it's legally now it's a
it's a rule i mean that's how it should
be i mean mature now you know
you know before like early days of
internet people would get away with that
kind of thing now it's like yeah they
did because it's on the internet so
they'll say you it's in an open space
but if the person didn't consent to it
yeah but you have to prove it right yeah
but you could you can watch it and you
know you've got again the professionals
yeah you can look and see if that person
would sorry you can see and if that
person was aware they were being
recorded yeah yeah you know and then
lines i think now it's been recorded but
i'm
filming now there's actually i think
there's law around oh before there
wasn't law
oh my god time to change so maybe there
should be consent to record
but
then there's consent to share if you say
you want to share it that's fine if you
say you don't want to share it and
that's your business no
i think there should be consent to share
it
but to record
i think if it's using like a court of
law and it hasn't been shared that
should be personally like i would never
want something recorded of me like out
there
you know like i just wouldn't want
someone to have the power to like
have that and i mean i i always hear
that guys show like nudes to their
friends and stuff girls do the same
thing
too
i'm not into like that stuff so right um
but i just wouldn't want something like
that of me out there so if i
if i was like dating someone and i found
out he like took that without me knowing
i would have oh my god i'd be pissed no
i know i hate i understand i understand
why it's not like i don't understand why
i'm just saying
we are living it's like
my whole thing is like there's an adapt
or die culture going on right now and a
lot of the people that don't adapt get
either eaten up or left behind in the
culture in which we live in an ideal
world no no one should record in anyone
we don't live in that world we live in a
world where people are going to go into
the trash and try and put a condom in
their vagina and get hot sauce instead
do you know what i mean so it's like if
we're living in that we're living in a
time a woman can write a book saying how
do you destroy a man by leveraging
this is the times we're living in so
it's like people are going to have to
adapt can i ask a question an important
question about that book who published
it
it's on amazon um is it self-published
or i i don't know who published it but
it's on amazon yeah i also was going to
add is that because it's quite
interesting about the whole recording
element as well because again in my
situation and it's what i mean about
protection and if it was the other way
around it wouldn't have been the case
but even when i brought forward to the
judge
the recordings they had no issue they
didn't want to see it
i would have to pay 5 000. so the court
was basically saying to me
to
to you know it's almost like strategize
let's go back to court in three months
if things change if things get better
then you know but that's why i was
interested in about this point about the
abuse because those scars that that
torment abuse violence and is it
coercive control that just has to sit
with me
and i'm good
but another man
not might have been even myself i do
question like how certain things why i'm
not in another place but
you know i think it's very important to
have these discussions
and that's why i said earlier
there
are cases and yours is a rare one when
you said that i was like whoa you had
evidence wow
where
mothers and women they can be
the worst of the worst but they'll still
have they'll still have their kids and
their father could be the right person
to take care of those kids and relieve
them of the situation that they're in
the mother literally has to be
the
bottom of the bottom of the bottom to
have her kids taken away she has to be
damn nearby
like abusing her children for a man it's
quick you do something wrong boom your
kids are taken away from your visitation
you gotta go and see them in visitation
and all this stuff yeah and i think it
should automatically just be 50 50
custody yeah like off the off the rep i
don't i don't think women automatically
are better parents just because they're
women
that's a misconception yeah and that's
good sorry i think if men were given
more chances to be parents in the sense
of the baby's born baby's breastfed
she's got to look after them she's got
to stay up at night or whatever it is
but i feel like because of the way
society is it doesn't encourage men to
be the night feeders it doesn't
encourage men to be the we don't have
breasts sorry i'm when i say night
feeders i mean in general like
my kid wasn't breastfed the whole time
he had bottles so really and truthfully
if he was encouraged to pick up that
bottle and say do you know what you
sleep i'm gonna feed and i'm gonna spend
it who's working who's going to work so
if he does that
is he going to work in the morning
to bring home to bring home to provide
for the house
only to be breastfeeding when he's
supposed to be sleeping because he's got
work the next day saying about there has
to be the balance in it yeah but that's
what i'm saying balance i'm not saying
it has to be all the time but if there
was more like if there was more
encouragement for men to be
more paternal
i wouldn't say maternal but let's just
say if they if they if it was more
encouraged and not looked down on
because when you see a man that's a stay
at home dad people are like men are men
are better single parents than mothers
on average
like that
but it's factual with statistics no i
mean i would agree i know some crazy
moms like i know i know okay all the
parents like i don't know to be honest
most of my friends growing up like
their parents stayed together but the
ones that i know that got divorced oh my
god i would i would 100 pick their dad
every single time because their mom was
freaking nuts
have you seen a mother always been have
you ever seen mother dairy said anyone
have you watched that it's a true film
she still have um i've heard it
so joanna crawford she's a hollywood
actress
what happened
she well basically she used to be she
abused her children but no one knew it's
one of her children came out later and
said it but it's called um
mother darius very very good very good
do you guys think um
do you guys think that
given the whole drake thing right do you
think that
there should be mandatory
um
dna tests when children are born yes
i mean now i would say that before you
say but absolutely yeah because i
actually i did that i feel like this is
oh hang on say that again i actually did
a dna test because of that yeah
definitely she let you do it she didn't
no this is the thing i didn't let her
know that i did it and i didn't even
tell her later that i did it but later
on
it had to come out that i did
you know because the dna test came out
mommy no i mean yeah i had to i mean
that's what i'm saying i'm not coming
here to be personal
it it's very difficult but you got to
realize that a lot of people having this
experience so it's more of a solution
basis to what we could do and then you
know once being twice shy no i agree i
feel like if there were mandatory dna
tests
there's no argument there's no
issue the child is either your child is
not yours and i think it would expose
those women that love to do up here's
your baby
and the thing is this is the thing about
because
you know what i'm going to say because
the problem is right there is that men
always can be accused of going around
having children a woman could be
sleeping around with other men and
there you go so and you're not going to
bring on two children so women can do it
and hide it you know what when i was
younger i would watch the mori show
and women would bring on 5 10 11 12 men
like oh this is my 20th time this is the
one and it's like how how do you
going back to earlier how women know
when they are ovulating and when they
are having sex how do you not know who
you have sex with in that
five-day span
to have you're doing that that much that
you don't know who your baby father is
understand women that how can you share
you and i'm sorry but how can you share
your body with so many people like
you're saying in such a short space of
time
it is disgusting you don't need to stop
okay just stop
the ginger but you know what do you know
that
do you know
this is one of the reasons yeah why this
is my personal rant now one of the
reasons why i think so many women are
upset at men speaking nowadays is
because men are realizing with the whole
mori show
with
just how manipu manipulative women can
be
and men generally didn't know that
before like i mean i think we knew you
know what i think it is it's when it
hits home
you know like we've all known
but when it actually happens to you yeah
you know and then you know what even
when it happens to you it's what levels
because again if it wasn't because of my
daughter's sake
i might have just
because it's about it's like the whole
thing obsession
men men can't be obsessive but women can
be assisted and it's accepted
that's very interesting
i am going to flip it on these shows you
do see these men that come on it's not
my baby it's not mine it's not mine but
you can see the child looks like oh
that's the silly thing a child looking
like someone this is subjective it turns
out to actually be their kids too yeah
so it's like
you really you sat you had a
relationship with the woman but because
you weren't truly truly in love with her
you didn't respect her you didn't care
for her so you didn't want the child to
be yours so you demonized the woman and
made it seem like oh she's sleeping
around she's doing she's doing that and
then it ended up to be yours no i
believe a lot of women fool themselves
into believing that they're actually in
relationships with men and they're just
having they just go yeah why why are
they picking these men like like it's on
you you say don't convince yourself
but the men the men do their
sorry the men do their best to basically
get the women to a stage where it's like
she really likes me men like to chase
they chase and then when they get they
discard oh no girls ignore red flags all
the goddamn time
we know the first three dates that this
man's a player and we keep going after
him and then we and then we go to the
internet and we cry boohoo
poor me i'm just like i'm in this
situation with the man that i picked
if you're a halfway attractive woman you
can date a million different guys that's
very true i remember guys pick
they pick so when a woman likes a guy
it's like no women are in control
women control access to sex men control
access to relationships so you are
picking the man
and he's only picking whether he wants
to be in a relationship once you've made
the decision that oh i'm going to allow
this man to have sexual access never
thought of it like that that's right
yeah and and my grandma would say
moreover it goes back to what
everyone said earlier man about you have
that con you if you have all them doubt
something paul is even saying if you had
that you don't have to have that child
so even if he's doing these things
you're a menarin you don't have to have
that child
i know everyone's got different reasons
of getting real child but i'm trying to
say you still have that power i just
can't get with this like victim like the
victim mentality i feel like as a woman
who we pick is our own fault and the
situations we get into our own faults
then if you're sleeping with a woman and
she gets pregnant or she'll understand
no no but i just say it's not the same
it's not the same with a man because as
a woman if we get pregnant we have the
option to not be a mother that is a
choice they don't get that choice
choosing where he ejaculates
into a condom that we can take
into account
but there is
there is always a fail-safe option for
women even if we get pregnant by the
wrong guy we can get half his income
but that men don't have that option and
if they do it it's an exception and it's
not the rule
you know it ties into it
is because there's that thing
do you know what it is there's that
thing where
cause you so you don't realize the fact
some women want women on their own
selfish gains yeah i've won that one
that child and now i'm selfish gains and
i think what poe is actually
highlighting it you still have the
option so all those doubts you ever met
you don't have to have that child you
can control if i have a condom if it
goes wrong what i can get the next day
to prevent iud
hang on like i said
being head of security for your own
vagina yeah means
anything that goes inside is on you